you may not realize how much of your ego  is tied up in you being the best at it I  think you just realized if you catch  yourself next week saying to him who's  like your number three guy you know I  would have done 42 and you did 47 and  that's why I'm if you feel those things  then your ego's tied in you're being  better and you've gotta create an ego  around something bigger  um  I double check a purchase order for her  like Jed I probably would have done that  because my ego having ego and self-worth  in something you did seven years ago  that you're better at than your  employees is just acting cool among  seven people for no reason  it makes sense right yeah  it's a big one listen I went through it  myself I still have those Tendencies  because you have pride in what you do  and you like it and you're like respect  your craft and you enjoy it but if  you're gonna really go there you need to  go there